eisen who is calling in from greenwich
connecticut good morning rich how are
you
i'm actually uh if you want to gps me uh
on the border of scarsdale and larchmont
new york right
hey now whoa are you off to play golf
what's happening i
am wow look at you i mean yeah i mean
we're working here
man of leisure richard you have a good
time tokyo gold
and then terrible golf so i don't know
what metal precious metal that would be
um
so that's what i got coleridge um how
are you guys doing
we're good i mean it's been good we're
having a heavy day yeah heavy day
yeah oh good i like it yeah yeah we have
a lot of callers we're asking them all
to hold on because we want to get to him
and
we're excited about it okay i'm i'm
white knuckling this
i don't know if uh you are brockman but
has is randall cobb officially a packer
he officially he officially tweeted this
morning i'm coming home so i think
that's a done deal
breaking news rich i mean dude you know
that brockman dipped his
toe in the in the in the world of news
and information
well actually we're we're calling him
brock now yeah he's an nfl insider
you have to like
rich i need to be officially referred to
as an nfl insider from now on thank you
oh my
god yeah i mean
he's really good about himself right now
i'm actually laughing about how
hilarious this all is but
it's fine look chefter and ian they
don't have to give me credit it's cool i
don't need the credit
that's not true that's how i thought i
didn't see your twitter feed
i saw somebody said you know at chris
brockman of the at rich eisen
and then the word show which is
upsetting to me because i was you know
i'm always wanting a brand new brand oh
right rich eisen show so that's how i
thought i'm like what the hell is here
and then i went to your twitter feed and
it's just you wrote it like your shelter
or
rap like are you gonna are you in rap
sheet gonna have like an anchorman type
throwdown like yeah
or what you can have i don't know he's
coming on later i guess we'll find out
yeah mcafee gave him props
oh yeah that's right pat was talking
about my tweet too yeah it's pretty
funny
pat all right well nfl insider chris
brockman i mean
he's always good for the first
information of the day do anything for
rich on any potential signings or not
signings in new york you know what else
no no i don't don't have anything else
zach wilson still not uh in cape but
trey lance is back so that's good
your sources haven't hit you up last one
right he's the last first rounder to be
zach wilson's the last one yeah
that's what that's what his uh nfl
sources that's what my sources are
telling me
i mean i can't even
i can't i mean i am well i am without
speech
i have no speech i i i i don't even know
how how you know i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna breathe easy
and you know and understand that the kid
will start week one
and it's
they're making a sausage i don't want to
know how it's getting made it's delayed
it's pissing me off and it's ridiculous
but just give him what he wants just
give him just
give him what he wants is it the most
jetsean thing to
draft your new franchise player and then
have him not there for the start of camp
i think this has happened before though
mcdonald's same thing with offset
language or whatever the hell it is
and they finally like three days later
gave him what he wanted it's just like
you know let's get going
let's get going you draft him you
screwed it up by winning too many games
then you draft him now we're all in on
him let's
be all in on it give him what he wants
get him in camp start it up
my gosh and of course for everybody
sitting back thinking mac jones is going
to be the second coming anyway he's
going to stroll in it's going to be
great for the patriots and
you know i i i mean it's just i'm just
going to breathe easy i'm on
i'm on the border of larchmont and
scarsdale i'll see it up
and that's what i'm gonna do i'm just
gonna do it and um and
and um and and i'm i'm without speech
what's the foursome today because
yesterday was what dp
and chap and reed no yeah well dan
suzie as you know dan comes up with
nicknames for people right
yes i've been on the tail end of that
so so his nickname for jeremy schaff
yesterday he's calling him shap
acquitted
oh wow jeez
all right chappaquin you know i just
like that i mean it's just like typical
d
and d dan was terrific dan was happy dan
yesterday
he wasn't he was happy dan is just
everything's good with dan
and his game is terrific and he was
giving jeremy some tips
and you know uh shap acuity was
uh within the drink a couple of times um
i mandated a day
he did all right i was not very good but
um it was just
great to be out there with old friends
and so that was a fun time
was it was dan giving him rich was he
giving him barbecue tips
or was he giving him golf tips well as
you know jeremy does not require
barbecue tips um
he is he has invited me over for a
barbecue over the next few days i don't
know when we haven't got a date but
um he's he loves he loves his barbecue
my god does he love it so but it was a
fun day you know
fun day oh here's one here's one for you
so you'll never guess who i ran into
in the elevator of my hotel you will
never guess
so i'm just going to come out and say it
martin scorsese
no no not even close brett hebert
no new york knicks head coach
tom thibodeau whoa whoa yes
it was one of those like what what's he
doing there
you're right we would have never guessed
what exactly that's why i finally gave
it to you
so you know the knicks the knicks um
train
you know near the connecticut new york
border and i guess that's why he was
there and
um i'm i'm in the elevator and you know
i'm masked up and
you know he's messed up and we're just
sitting there talking and i just like
pull my mask down real quick and just
say hi it's rich eisen figuring that
you know he goes back to the
sportscenter days he's been in the nba
for
quite some time and you know he either
acted like he knew me or he really did
know me
and as soon as like he was very you know
he recognized who i was
i immediately got white with a little
bit of panic
that he knows about the dolan
[Laughter]
i got very self-conscious in the
elevator
which goes very slowly in my hotel very
slowly
it just started taking away and it's one
of those moments where
like okay he knows i hate the man
that um pays him um but he could not
have been uh
any nicer tom timido little signing all
right a little exciting for me how about
how about that
how about that that's my story i got
nothing else
that's a great story that's a great have
i blown up the flow of this program
calling in no wait who are you golfing
with today
oh um my buddy reed again and two other
people you don't know
okay so keen it up gonna play and
i don't know what i'm gonna get to play
again this week and tokyo gold was a lot
of fun today
um good times with that one today nice
sigh of relief for the u.s men's
national team
uh taking care of um iran
um wait can i can i interrupt for a
second right there yes
i mean i was looking at espn.com this
morning as as i was prepping for the
show and they're like you know
we saw what we needed from usa
basketball
it's iran yeah did we i mean it wasn't
like 120
66 maybe they were 41 point favorites
we saw what we needed out of usa men's
basketball it's iran
i mean isn't that they don't have yeah
no they don't have it's crazy
nba players and the next team that they
play the czech republic does not have
any nba players but as i was leaving
uh nbc headquarters i was watching
australia and the italians take on each
other
and the italians have gallinari the uh
the aussies have
you know patty mills they've got some
players it's a different ball of wax now
the nba's everywhere
luca lurks with slovenia you know and
um so yeah i guess we needed to see what
we saw which was like a 60-point
smackdown and they should beat the czech
republic
too but it'll be i think it's definitely
going to be a
a tight grip of the wheel at 10 and 2
when they start to play
elimination matches that's coming by the
way chris is um
very big on luca being the most
impactful and most important
super super hot take from last week rich
yeah
it was maybe it was monday if lucas
somehow because you know he dropped 48
which was just shy of the olympic record
first 40 point game since like 96.
if luca somehow leads slovenia to a
medal
he's already jumped giannis as the best
player in the world
are you guys forcing me to have a take
involving giannis again because
that's the worst thing i've ever had in
the history of happiness we're
giving you a shot at redemption what was
the take
my cake was oh susie it's so bad what
was the tanker
this is from last year it was bad it's
from last year because the miami heat is
you know made the finals
and giannis was supposedly up for grabs
because he hadn't signed a supermax
contract yet
and i was saying that i would not break
up the miami heat i would not send
tyler hero and you know
uh what bam out of bio for honest i
wouldn't
i and a bunch of products yeah i
wouldn't i wouldn't break up the heat
for
uh for giannis for and for two weeks i
had to like go
are you sure about this yes wouldn't do
it
every day we brought it up like really
you wouldn't trade for giannis
that's like when you go into your emojis
and you find the the
what's it called the gif or gif or
whatever and there's like dancing
beyonce and all that
that's when you find like the most
ridiculous one of like somebody from the
office making a face like what
yeah yeah you really did that that's
awful but but i did uh yeah
right it is right that's why i copped to
it a few weeks ago when the heat got
eliminated and
and it keeps moving on and then it just
got worse
so you're forcing me now to say
luca if he leaves slovenia to a medal
he's the best player in the world
yeah so like you know gluca's like 50
points of the
you know games selena's never even
qualified
for the olympics before no rich let me
let me preface this by telling you last
week with
with ben lyons as ben and i were talking
and trying to hype up carmelo
and i brought up the fact that carmel is
the greatest u.s olympian of all time
brockman said it didn't matter so it
went from
the olympics and winning gold not
mattering to
72 hours later if luca wins a goal then
he's the best so all of a sudden the
olympics matters so
i'm confused i'm not sure about you yeah
by the way durant needs six points
against the czech republic to pass
yeah carmelo for most points all the
time
i was watching that last night and
thinking of ben lyons and wondering if
ben was just sitting there like just
crying like but he's got another game
he's got another game all right i'll
answer it i mean
come on giannis put up a 50 piece in in
winning a championship
in milwaukee come on now man but this is
a
slovenia who wins a medal i i i know
slovenia can if slovenia met up i'll
still stick with giannis
because i'm i'm scarred with my life
i mean i think you can't go wrong with
the honesty that's my that's my safer
bet
enriching rich again last night i'm
watching you and i
ended up calling chris about 2 33 and we
were chatting
and i was like bro i you know i'm not
going to say this the rich
person but i'll say it to you on the
phone i was like this guy is
crushing this right now like it's it's
really impressive like rich's shuttle
clock minute
is is amazing and like you're doing
great work man it's
it's impressive to watch thank you i'm
having a blast and
um um you know i'm needing to i think
you know edit myself uh today i almost
with the shuttlecock minute was the you
were feeling that a lot yesterday the
sport the sport was judo and i
almost said i put the jew in judo i
decided not to
wow um yeah i almost did that but suzy
i gave i i thought of you for a line
today which is
when uh the uh italian fencer
um advanced to the gold medal against
korea which is tomorrow
the uh his italian teammates jumped on
top of him
i called said that's an italian pig pile
which in the world of meats and cheeses
is called charcuterie
that's one of my favorite words well
done i thought of using
but what's so crazy is charcuterie's not
even an italian word
you should have said moto prosciutto see
no no i i i know but i i but charcuterie
is what you get is a it's a it's a plate
of italian meats and cheeses
meats and cheeses it is well it's really
french but that's neither here nor there
let's not
break this down goodness
can i ask can i ask this is my of my
husband
were all the italian guys really
handsome
oh my god you know this the last thing i
want is to have this italian
fencer take off his hood and you see
what's on his hair
yeah oh yeah by the way you were you
were this happened what was it two weeks
ago
wasn't djokovic took on an italian guy
because we're trying to show her hey
because she's into tennis he's taking
tennis lessons like this is what it's
like at the highest level
our daughter is sitting there and then
they show the italian guy
uh on screen and susie's like oh god
in front of our daughter he's like i'm
sitting right here
yes hello yes so the italian right and
the brazilian guy
was surfing they're all yeah no no
none of them are they're all they're all
big they're all big men on campus
they're all big men in country that's
what they are all right rich rich what
was your
olympic moment of the day what was your
favorite highlight today on tokyo
um well that fencing was pretty wild
um did you say on guard you must have
right
um a little parry we did a little bit of
that i had david ferrity on
how was that i had debbie parody on to
play our tokyo game time game show
and we showed him the uh uh the
olympic uh synchronized divers
in their very they're very
tight um speedos and he called them
plum snugglers wow
that's a fantastic i love it that's
that's almost as good as butt huggers
that's one of those things like did you
know you say that
yeah he called them plum snugglers is
what ferrari
called it and he makes it sound even
better in his uh in his brogue
so that was fun today um and tomorrow's
dale jr is coming on so
it's fun i'm having a blast but he's
incredibly timely to have on
actually with everything that's
happening with the olympics because not
only does he understand the pressure
of taking over for his dad and his dad's
fans would have you but he also
spoke about his anxiety with driving
he's like the perfect guy
to talk about in terms of everything
with the olympics and you'll probably
play
one of one of your great games yes we
will play
we'll just play a game with him instead
sure why not
all right keep your head down hit him
straight thank you all right take care
thanks for coming in all right brother
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here